[Applause]
Jordan never once has Jordan said I'm
sorry I'm sorry what is it like for you
to watch that back to relive that really
tough time that you went through
I personally don't watch it back because
I just I already know what happens and
it it's just I think a little too toxic
for me to keep reliving stuff like that
so I stay off social I don't I didn't
watch it and it's just a part of our job
that we kind of have to do so we can't
just pick and choose what we want to
show that's not fair and so that's just
what it is well Scott I liked you really
defended Chloe yeah what was going
through your mind are you upset for her
what did you want to happen for her
during all that well the truth of the
matter was I think a lot of people
started getting too caught up and the
negative side of things when in
actuality the only thing that really
matters is Chloe and our baby true and
that's it nothing else and all support
should be going for her and how she
feels and that's it this has happened to
a million people in the world let's just
figure out how to get Chloe through it
not figure out how to get any negativity
in it and I just think it
she's what matters her baby's what
matters I think we're feeling okay that
gnashing either side it's just not cool
for me fashion is for anybody I don't
think there needs to be negativity on
anywhere I think it's just a story
that's being told but anybody picking
aside or you know condemning any human I
think this is a part of life I'm not
saying it was yeah but there's way too
many people that thing got involved yeah
then felt like it was their story and
felt like they needed to let's just
focus on what's real and what's
happening because all these other things
aren't gonna change and they're not
gonna help anything you realize what
really is important and that's yourself
did I get myself into what's next for
Chloe promoting season 3 of revenge body
and celebrating her 35th birthday just
click or - even have a little bit of a
revenge body now like how you feeling
yeah yeah I thought I would be a little
more insecure because I worked so hard
to get my body before I got pregnant
what I felt really good I think after
you have a baby you just feel empowered
and just the fact that you're now able
to juggle a child working out and work
I think that's an accomplishment so I
felt really good that I found my groove
and that I was trying when you talk in
the trailer about this season being
about transforming not just body but
soul and mind where are you at for
yourself on that mind soul journey right
now um I really think I'm in a good
place but I think working on your
personal growth internally is something
that will be a forever mission and I
always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally because that's how we
become better people while the world is
changing around us we should adapt to
that too but always remember to be kind
and just courteous of what's happening
around you too so I don't ever want that
to change
[Music]